- Back at it with the
Doctor Reacts series.
This week, I'm tackling "Scrubs."
(energetic music)
This show is supposed to be a comedy,
but I've also heard that it's rated
one of the most medically
accurate shows out there.
Let's find out.
(rock music)
Lie number 1: doctors
don't wake up at 6:00 a.m.
We wake up at 4:00 a.m. or
5:00 a.m. at the lastest,
because usually, we have
patients scheduled for 6:00 a.m.
Or if we're gonna be on a hospital shift,
you need to come in for
rounding and pre-rounding.
I don't know what kind
of doctor this guy is,
but 6:00 a.m. is a bit late.
(rock music plays)
(sirens wine)
- And four years of pre-med,
four years of med school,
and tons of unpaid loans have
made me realize one thing.
- Good, could you go drop an
NG tube on the patient in 234,
and call the attending that
the lavage is positive?
- I don't know jack.
- (chuckles)
Your first day in the
hospital is a scary day.
And I'm not talking about
when you're a medical student
on your clinical rotations
because no one really
expects much from you
when you're a medical student.
When you go in as a
resident, you're a doctor,
you have a medical degree,
so people have expectations
that you'll know what you're doing.
Now, just because you have the knowledge
from a textbook on how
to accomplish something,
it doesn't mean that you
have firsthand experience
and hands-on experience really matters,
especially when you're
dealing with other people.
Because medicine is about
dealing with people,
not disease.
- The hospital doesn't want
to be sued
- (laughs)
- Being sued is not
a good thing
- (chuckles)
- Finally, doctors,
if there is a mistake
don't admit it to the patient.
- Here's a fun fact about this:
common sense-wise, you may think that yes
if you hide the fact
that you made a mistake,
you're less likely to get sued,
but what research has
actually shown is that
if you're honest and come
clean about your mistake,
which doctors totally make mistakes
we're not robots.
If you come clean about your mistakes,
and show the proactive steps you've taken
to prevent that mistake
form occurring again,
patients are less likely to sue you.
Patient's families are
less likely to sue you.
So it's about owning up.
It's about being a good person.
And if you're a human first,
you're less likely to get sued.
- I'm a tool, I am a tool,
I am a tool, tool, tool,
an unbelievably annoying tool.
- Yeah.
Finally, these are your beepers,
from now on, they
control your entire life.
- (chuckles) You would actually think that
because it's 2018
or at least when I was doing residency,
it was 2017, you wouldn't
have beepers anymore.
Guess what?
We still have those same pagers!
It's crazy!
I actually had the communications people
from the hospital send
the message to my phone
instead of to the pager,
and I actually had them change that.
To me, it just felt way to old-school
to be walking around with
one of those pagers on me.
- You've done this to cadavers before.
So, this guy's alive, just
poke it through his skin.
Poke it through! Now!
- (laughs)
- (whistles) Time's up.
Carla, would you do it for him, please?
I'm also gonna need an ABG.
- Why are you telling her?
- Shut up and watch.
- (snorts) Okay, this is
actually really funny.
Very true that when you
go in your first day,
some of the senior
doctors will want to see
your ability to do some of the procedures,
like put an IV in,
to do an ABG, which is
an arterial blood gas.
It's basically when
you go into the artery,
usually the radial artery,
which is at the end of your wrist.
It's one of the harder sticks
because you can see veins,
the artery you actually
have to feel the pulse,
and then insert the needle based on
where you're feeling the pulse.
- Doctor Dorian, can you tell me
what ailment most often--
- I think I'm gonna love rounds.
It's like being on a game-show.
(bell dings)
What is uremia?
- That's my boy!
- This is a cool example
of what rounds are.
You basically have a list of patients
that your team is responsible for
and you go around with your entire team
with the attending being in charge,
sometimes it's the chief of medicine,
and you walk around to
each patient's bedside
and you discuss the case,
not only with the patient,
but with the team as well.
Sometimes you get the
doctor asking you questions.
That's a form of pimping.
They're trying to get you
to think outside the box.
The way that I like to lead rounds is:
sometimes, we know already
what the patient has,
because it's written on our reports,
but I would say,
"Well, what if this test
came back negative?"
or "What if Mr. Johnson
presented without the headaches?
What would change in your diagnoses?"
And that way, it can
facilitate how a person thinks
because the quality of a good doctor
is being able to adapt.
It's to be able to think on the spot.
Back in the day, they were very mean
about this pimping process,
and if you didn't get it right,
they would talk down to you,
they would call you stupid.
I don't see that negativity there anymore.
And I think the whole process has become
a lot more positive reinforcement-based.
- I'm going for it
(grunts) Infection.
- Infection?
- That's my girl!
Moving on.
- I knew the answer!
- I'm sure you did.
- I was just frazzled--
- How could you not be?
- You know, thick--
- Oh, I know, yeah.
- Good.
But thanks, if there anything
I can ever do for you, just--
- You could let me take you
to dinner tomorrow night.
- We're back to the sex.
Even a comedy medical show
that is funny on its own
still needs to have a
little sex thrown in there.
(crowd gasps)
(laughter)
(clapping)
- What the hell are you doing?
(record scratches)
- All those newspapers
are very legitimate,
like, having a ton of
newspapers just sprawled about
that are very old.
Having that horrible TV that's,
like, sitting way to high up
so you have to jack your neck up.
You daydream a lot,
especially when you've
been up for 24 hours.
So that part of this is very realistic.
- Did you actually just page me
to find out how much Tylenol
to give to Mrs. Lensner?
- (laughs)
- I was worried that it could
exacerbate the patient's--
- It's regular strength Tylenol.
Here's what you do:
Get her to open her mouth,
take a handful, and throw it at her.
Whatever sticks, that's
the correct dosage.
- (laughs)
I'm gonna be honest and say that
I've done stuff like this.
My first rotation going into residency was
on the surgical unit.
And I texted senior
residents or attendings
for everything.
And then after a few weeks, I realized
"Why am I doing this?"
If I know it's the answer
and I've double-checked
that it's the answer,
why am I asking for permission
when I have a Doctorate degree.
So it takes some time
to build up confidence,
not every person works at the same pace.
So I totally get where he's coming from
asking about the Tylenol.
- For the love of god, what?
- It's just, do you
really think we should be
talking about this in front of her?
- Her? She's dead.
(woosh)
- Oh my god.
All right, this show's crazy.
- If they find out the nurses
are doing your procedures
for you, your ass will
be kicked outta here
so quick it'll make your head spin.
- Nurses do the majority of the procedures
as it is now.
If the procedure's too difficult,
you're the one that's responsible
to come in and solve that problem.
If then you can't do it,
then you can escalate to
either another resident
or maybe the attending physician.
But generally, nurses are
better at doing the procedures
than us because they do
them so much more often.
So their hands are much more well-equipped
to do the procedures.
- I'm not really dead.
- (chuckles) This is suck a wicked show.
(whip cracks)
- Ow
(laughter)
And like that, I was back in high school.
You see, surgical interns, they're all
slice 'em and dice 'em.
They're the jocks.
Medical interns, we're trained
to think about the body,
diagnose, test.
The medical interns, well--
- Hey you got a stain.
Ah ha-ha!
- We're the chess club.
- (groans)
Not exactly accurate, but
has some truth behind it.
Surgical interns and residents
are much more practical,
they see a problem, they want to fix it.
They want to go in and
cut, reassemble, suture,
whereas, as a medical intern or resident,
you have to really think about:
Is this patient gonna
follow the treatment?
Is this medicine gonna interact
with all these other medications?
Sometimes, surgery will consult
us, as the medical team,
to come in and manage something
that very simple for us,
but to them it's something
that they don't do often.
Whereas on the other hand,
we'll call for their help
on simple surgical procedures,
even like sutures if they
get too complicated for us.
It's really about teamwork
and making it a balanced approach.
(pager beeps)
- My first code.
See, here's how it works:
Someone's heart fails,
they beep everyone,
the first doctor in has to run the room,
tell everyone what to do,
basically decide if the
patient lives or dies.
What am I, crazy?
(door slams)
(gasps)
- (gasps)
- In general, you have a code team
that's set to respond to these code blues.
Yes, it's about you gets there first,
but it's not about,
"Any doctor in the hospital
should just run up and
start treating the patient."
We have teams dedicated for this,
'cause imagine if everyone's
busy and no one responds.
What, the person just ends up dying?
Not the case.
There's strict responsibilities here.
In my hospital, the way it worked was
the ICU on-call teams
usually ran the code,
and if there was something else going on,
then the medical team
came in and ran the code.
Not gonna lie, it was scary
when you would have one code
and then another code
happened simultaneously,
and then maybe a rapid response,
meaning that someone's heart didn't stop
but something serious is happening
where their heart may stop soon,
and at the same time you get an admission.
It can get really hectic.
- Hey, Champ.
First night on call starts soon, huh?
Gosh, you must be excited.
- (screams)
You betcha.
- The first night I was on call,
I was terrified.
'Cause you have one senior attending,
and if they get busy with something,
it's all on you, and you're so worried
about making the wrong decision.
But if you double-check
everything that you do,
speak to people who have
more experience than you
when you aren't sure about what to do,
you're gonna be fine.
While those nerves are
totally normal and expected,
there are ways to combat it.
By being informed, by being knowledgeable,
and by being smart. (laughs)
(pager beeps)
- (sighs)
(somber music)
- I can relate to the
feeling of coming on call
and instantly getting things to do.
For me, my calls start at 7:00 p.m.
So when I would go in at 7:00 p.m.,
the team that's coming off would hand off
the pager to me and say,
"Hey, we were so behind that there's still
three or four admissions that
are in the emergency room
that need to be done and
brought into the hospital."
So you come in, and you
already have stuff to do.
And then on top of that,
you're getting pages
about new things that are going on.
- The attending thinks it
was a pulmonary embolism.
No way anyone could have caught it.
Anyhow, you have to pronounce him.
- Why didn't anybody page me?
- Could you just pronounce
him so I can go home?
- Okay, so this is an interesting thing.
Pronouncing someone dead is usually done
by the on-call resident,
so that's accurate.
What happens is if a person
dies in the hospital,
the nurse pages the on-call resident,
they have to do a full exam.
We look at the pupillary response,
pain threshold,
we put a pen on the nail bed
and we press very heavily
so if the patient is somehow not dead
they would wake up.
We listen to the heart,
we listen to the lungs
for an extended period of time.
There's like this whole
physical exam that we do.
And then, we write it in a long note
calling the time of death,
suspected cause of death.
In addition to that, once
you pronounce the patient
you have to talk to the family,
which is a very difficult conversation.
You mature very quickly
during these moments.
- Even now, when I finally get to go home,
in the back of my head I'll know
the hospital's still here, wide awake.
- That line is very true.
There's been times I was
in a good mood to go home
and I was like,
"Let me just stroll through the ER."
And something happened and I
needed to help someone out,
and I end up staying three,
four, five hours past my shift.
It's one of those things.
Go home while you still can,
'cause you need to be
back here the next night
to save lives.
- The most important thing
is that I got through
my first three days without looking
like a complete idiot.
(thuds)
- (snorts)
Another episode of the
Doctor Reacts series
is in the books.
Mixed feelings on this
one, and that's surprising
'cause I thought I would
find it really funny.
There was definitely
parts that had me laughing
and I was like,
"Yeah, that's so true."
But I don't know, some parts were just
so dark and mean-spirited
that I couldn't get behind it.
It pushes a lot of the stereotypes
on the medical community that
aren't good to be pushing.
We should be getting rid of them
instead of celebrating them.
I probably need to watch more episodes
to truly understand what the
characters are all about.
If you like this type of content,
please subscribe down below.
'Cause it tells YouTube that
you really enjoy this content,
and it allows me to continue
making this type of content.
And if you have a show that you love,
or specific episodes
of the "Scrubs" series
that you want me to watch,
leave it down below in the comments.
As you know, I react to
the comments all the time.
If not in the comments section,
in my monthly responding
to comments video.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(relaxed music)